what exactly
you know when i when i was coming up
listening to hip-hop i feel like there
was
there was like lines that a lot of
people didn't cross now tupac
and biggie you know pocket hit him up
which is which was a pretty pretty
scathing record but
um i know a lot of people have passed in
your situation
but where's the line man because i feel
like there is no line and these these
like
like the records you put out with with
you know being at the gravesite and all
that [__]
that's a that's like is there a is
that something you think you might
regret one day man cause i feel like you
know that's a real
death is a real sacred thing yeah and i
feel like uh
you know unfortunately it just feels
like it's it between both of these songs
and this beef it just feels like it's
it's
there's just zero lines like
everything's been crossed like it's
um oh i ain't gonna say
it's a well i ain't gonna cabbage to be
honest ain't no line like [__] like in
my city
nobody don't go [__] on bro like
everybody's straight
on goal like 24 7 something ain't no
line they just keep getting
escalated and up oh oh you know what i'm
saying
that's just how it is are you worried
like cause my thing is is like
i feel like the kind of energy y'all
playing with like
it's more people will end up dead man
you know what i'm saying
it's it's it's we've we've lost so many
people in music you know you've lost so
many of your friends
yeah when is like to you when it's like
enough enough oh
[__] i say
hmm
really is not nor enough cause it is
it's just a straight playing field ain't
no rules in the street
so people doing whatever to get at
people either way whether it's
songs catching a [__] with his wife
whatever [__] doing whatever to catch
[__] what happened to you right your
girl got shot is that why car got shut
off your car got shot your girl was in
the car right yeah i went in the car she
was driving
up did she get hit yeah but she could
yeah
again right like that's something that
under normal circumstances you would
think is
like i you know what i'm saying off
limits if that makes sense yeah
but it seems like with with what
whatever's going on
in jacksonville [__] is really really
there's no like i said there's just no
lines and and i don't know if there's
something to
i don't know man i just i just i would
hate to open my phone
and see your name on academics and be
like you know
or see even see aces name you know what
i'm saying like the end of the day both
of y'all came out the same city
both of you guys are are making money
off this rap [__] you know what i'm
saying
i just i don't i just i would i don't
know if there's i mean when i understand
when people lose their life it's
it's really no like there's nothing else
to be talked about but at the same time
like you would hope there would be some
sort of resolution
to stop any sort of future you know
situations that might put you in harm or
or anybody else in harm
definitely